تنظم تظاهرات جديده اليوم في عموم فرنسا
من قبل جمعيات ومنظمات شبابيه تحمل شعارات
تدين عنف الشرطه الفرنسيه وذلك بعد
انتهاكات كثيره خلال قمع التحركات
الاحتجاجيه الاخيره التحركات تحتاج ايضا
على رفع سن التقاعد وتضامنا مع منظمه
يساريه طلبه وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه حلها
الرئيس الفرنسي كان قد دعى النقابات
والمحتاجين الى التهدئه مشيرا الى ان
المجلس الدستوري سيفحص نص قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد بحكمه وهدوء واضاف مكروه ان
الحوار مستمر بين الحكومه والنقابات التي
لها الحق في التعبير عن رايها من خلال
التظاهرات بعيدا عن اعمال التخريب ومشاهد
العنف مؤكدا على ان الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه
لا تعني ان كل شيء يجب ان يتوقف
موسيقى
نعلم ان هناك معارضه ضد اصلاح نظام
التقاعد لهذا السبب ستلتقي رئيسه الوزراء
بالنقابات الاسبوع المقبل وهناك تحركات
مسموح بها في اطار ديمقراطيتنا وحوار
مستمر كما ان هناك اطرا زمنيه يمكن من
خلالها تحقيق المسار الديمقراطي لمشروع
القانون ايضا هناك نص موجود في المجلس
الدستوري الذي سيدرسه بحكمه وهدوء الهدوء
مطلوب لاجراء النقاش